qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
banlieues qui prennent feu au moment
même où vous sortez votre premier disque
pour arrêter de tout confondre les
gallois ont fait du rab comprend des
micros on prend pas des fentes d'autres
étaient espérés
vit dans un immeuble les avait joués une
société qui fait tourner le regard
[Musique]
la prochaine fois je me fais tatouer un
drapeau bleu blanc rouge sur le cul
histoire de faire gagner du temps à tout
le monde
[Musique]
fait un truc dans ta vie et on en
reparle on a toujours fonctionné comme
ça on trace notre route ensemble on
n'aura pas de deuxième chance qu'on
transporte aujourd'hui c'est nous de
montrer qu'on est moins c'est hors de
question que je retrouve mon étaient des
faux plafonds et honda si tu veux en
gros - bruno occupe d'écrire des textes
et djs derrière et s'occupe du bit tu
crois pas que tu me fout la honte avec
tourne ta mère partout la fois ce nom
des bills a partout sur les murs
faut être intelligent pour faire de la
musique
je prie thouars je peux le voir pour ça
c'est mal barré jeudi
j'ai dit à mes
concurrents les violences verbales ne
sont plus cantonnées à mes côtés comme
en arrière c'est clair
niktamère le
les sites et saucissons tard lorsque la
libre et que les gens des quartiers
n'ont jamais eu peur de la pénombre
chance d'habiter là
redescend si je monte pas sur scène avec
toi car invisible
nous
[Musique]